the Democrats really love people who are
reliant on the machine they want to tell
you what to think they want to regulate
what soda you can or cannot have what
you're injecting in yourself whether
you'll go to school what you will learn
at that school
etc etc
and this is directly related to the fact
that most of the Democrat Party at this
point the base is purely sort of
secularism on steroids now again I'm not
telling every I'm not telling anyone
actually what to believe or how to
worship or anything else but to get
again to the thesis if you don't believe
in something you will just believe in
exactly what is happening
right now and you will look for answers
from people who actually don't have any
answers at all here's a bit on that from
my friend Russell Brandt when it says in
the Old Testament worship no other gods
than me
the implication I offer is that we are a
species that worships and if you do not
access the Divine you will worship the
Mundial you will worship the profane you
will worship your own identity you will
worship your belongings you will worship
the template Lane before you buy a
culture that wants you no wants you that
gets you distracted and relative every
time okay so what's interesting about
that is okay he's he's laying out
something similar to what I've laid out
here I don't think there's anything
wrong with material things I don't think
there's anything wrong with capitalism I
don't think there's wrong with having a
big house or the cars you want or
whatever you a boat or yacht whatever
you want but that cannot be the sum
totality of everything right it just
simply cannot be but once you disconnect
belief in something other than What's
Happening Here Right Here and Now then
when weird things happen say covet say
they just tell you there's a pandemic
whether it's real or it's not you will
end up worshiping
the power that you've ceded to them
right you will worship the people who
somehow seem like the expert class
laughs
[Music]